by the way uh mark hamill even uh uh  tweeted out  lots of them  really sticking it to the man uh you  watch some of the recent star wars yeah  well that's also he also unfortunately  tweeted out this picture which just  seems like you know this is what we're  talking about it's not appropriate  ruining a children's disney disney come  on  suck it you will yes  your daddy i am  you're fart  your father will watch  watch your dad  [Laughter]  and your legs  right here you say  no  okay is that the dark side no it's just  him they're role-playing  the point is they're consenting adults  it's totally what yoda and luke do in  their own bedroom is their own business  well fine it is part of the jedi  training